what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host na Saki and we are at the
fifth annual raw Science Film Festival
we have been celebrating incredible
films in science and technology
inspiring the next generation of
builders and giving them really epic
awards for their good work it's a long
time coming that we celebrate scientists
with this much health and vigor so we
are now blessed to be talking to dr. Kip
Thorne hello great to see you thank you
so much for chatting with us we really
appreciate it
for those that don't know Kip is a Nobel
laureate in 2017 in physics he has had
waves and waves get it gravitational
waves of impact on our world and physics
and so much more so Kip I want to start
off with a big history perspective on
civilization we find ourselves here as
stewards of Earth after such a long time
of evolution and we're kind of hockey
sticking up in population and
exponential technologies what is your
current synthesis of humanity
humanity should take great joy in the
world and great joy in each other we are
in this all together and we need to
behave like we're all together and like
we're all friends and we're all in a
quest to enjoy the universe and explore
the universe and what can we best do to
increase the awareness of others to the
point of that we are all in this quest
to enjoy life on earth together and go
outward into the cosmos I think that
film plays a big role in inspiring and
educating particularly inspiring and
making people adopt some some view of
each other and of the world and so the
film is powerful and that's why we're
here celebrating the raw science film
festival celebrating the synthesis
between science and film and they have
effectiveness of film in promoting some
understanding of and belief in faith in
enthusiasm about science agreed this is
one of the most powerful mediums is
video and we can leverage it to
disseminate the feelings of unity to
more people around the world Kip I think
it's really important to talk about this
you've been at the edge of knowledge
there's kind of a base camp of knowledge
that we learn in school and then there's
an edge of knowledge which is you get
yourself out to where it's the cutting
edge of what humans know about a
specific field and you've been there in
physics and you've been there pushing
and pushing continuously that edge what
has what drives you to that edge of
knowledge and and what sustains you at
magic knowledge I think a big part of it
is not having lost to curiosity that I
was born with if you take a look child
age 3 or 4 or 5 the child's just full of
questions about the universe that gets
beat out of them all too
well fortunately it didn't get beat out
of me and so here I am and here's what I
am done for my whole career is keeping
trying to understand questions through
the drive to understand the drive of
curiosity human curiosity that curiosity
that's right that's right retaining it
as a lifelong learner throughout our
entire life okay and then what would be
obviously curiosity but give us maybe
two more principles that we should
embody to maximize our ability to get
from that base camp out to the edges of
knowledge I think that in the quest to
understand the universe as in so many
other human quests the learning how to
concentrate and focus learning how to
select the thing as you work on the
select the things you pay attention to
is tremendously important it's a really
in many ways much more important than
the actual specific knowledge that
you're taught in school and it is
something that I throughout my career I
tried to ingrain into mine
students that focus and concentration is
so crucial especially in the exponential
age of information as well and
distraction susceptibility to
distraction that's a very powerful one
and do we live in a very mathematical
universe at times it seems like we're
learning more and more code about how
it's run but when you go deep into the
nature of the universe you discover that
the laws of nature which control the
universe and control how things change
in the natural universe those laws are
written in the language of mathematics
so mathematics does not tell us what the
laws are but you have to master
mathematics in order to understand the
laws in order to deal with the laws in
order to make predictions in order to
use the laws for technology so
mathematics is a crucial and central
tool in Internet technology as well as
science
tip is our next evolution to a few
humans from single-cell multi-cell human
artificial general intelligence is that
our next evolutionary step I don't know
but I suspect our next evolutionary step
in some sense is a synthesis between
artificial intelligence and our
intelligence and learning to work with
machines or they may be some but
biologically based machines that are
smarter than we are in some ways but are
very not at all likely to be smarter
than we are in some crucial ways like
from the heart well from the heart but
also it's going to be a long time until
I think that artificial intelligence has
the levels of creativity than the human
but they will say I think the synthesis
between human minds and efforts on
machine Minds is going to be the key
least over the next 20 30 40 years and
what is the next area of math and
physics that gives you the most
excitement for us to make new
discoveries it for me the biggest quest
is to understand the birth of the
universe to understand the laws that
govern the birth of the universe from
those laws we don't know we don't
understand they're called the laws of
quantum gravity but I hope that by the
time I die and I plan to live to a
hundred and ten so that that gives me
some 40 30 years more we're gonna
gradually freeze you and we'll kill you
lied on me are you I want to enjoy every
step along the way but I hope that by
that time I think it's likely by that
time we will have these laws of quantum
gravity in our hands we will be
beginning to explore the birth of the
universe using them
to understand how this all came to be
cute
what what would you hypothesize is what
caused this to come to these I don't
know as I said just like a scientist
what do you thinks the most beautiful
thing in the world
well to me people in the most beautiful
thing in the world
and what specific aspects I think
they are the entity that gives me the
greatest joy second greatest is making a
great scientific discovery
I love it tip I love it and I'll keep
this we'll keep this short will as we'll
let you get going we'll hopefully have
you on our show for longer format
conversation more deeper depth into
things soon thanks everyone for tuning
in Thank You Kip for coming on we
greatly really did it thanks so much
thank you everyone give us your thoughts
in the comments below we'd love to hear
from you support great people like Kip
raw science Film Festival shows like our
simulation go and build the future
everyone much love and we'll see you
soon
peace